[Music]
so I think most of the extreme cases are
not actually that extreme I think one
it's just empathy at the beginning just
understanding that your parents love you
people don't see from the other side
your parents love you they want you to
succeed
almost every every parent wants their
kids to succeed it's 99.9% of parents
want their kids to succeed right the
0.1% they generally like hate their kids
like those people exist but but most
parents they want their kids to succeed
they just have a different definition of
success success to them is go to go to
school get a job even if you hate it
spend the next 40 years doing that it's
safe reliable income and and you know
get married to the opposite sex half
dream to have kids and the dog and all
that and write this they have a view of
success that's been passed down from
generation to generation this generation
in particular the rate of change has
happened so quickly
but we're growing up in an era that our
parents don't understand the
opportunities that you have as a young
person growing up today we're not
available to your parents the idea of
I'm gonna make videos from my cell phone
and just make a huge career out of that
is ridiculous
so understand that to them it seems
ridiculous because it absolutely is
we're just growing up in that world so
it makes sense that people are starting
to win but it makes sense for your
parents to see it as ridiculous and so
just some some empathy then they're
saying that they love you they want you
to have success they just don't
understand your world and you could try
to convince some you can say you know
why don't you want to understand my
world but but understanding that they're
coming from a place of love even if
they're yelling at you is I think the
first step next is having just the
honest conversation if then I supporting
you saying this is something I need to
try this is something I want to do you
know I don't like being an AC repair man
I want to be a videographer you know
what it may not work out you may be
right like I may be the worst
photographer of all time I could I could
lose everything I have
and and have to sleep on somebody's
couch I need to know
I need to know and I hope that if I have
to sleep on somebody's couch that you'll
give me the couch to sleep on
and that's that idea of chasing your
dream and needing to know is a message
that a lot of parents can connect with
[Music]
and understanding that they may have a
high degree of failure but you still
need to know because what the parents
are seeing is this this my kids gonna
fail he's gonna be unhappy he's gonna go
broke and all you're putting out is this
is for sure gonna work look at all these
people making it happen of course is
gonna work and they think you're you
think you're being ignorant they think
you're missing a perspective they think
you don't have the data and I think
you're gonna lose but if you're
approaching in the fact that I probably
will lose like the data is against me
I've thought this through but I still
need to know I need to know and I hope
you'll support me through it it's a
total different conversation then I need
to as parents you never support me you
never tell me that I can win why are you
so mean to me like as soon as you start
attacking you put at them on the defense
and you lose so having that honest
conversation I think that I think
empathy to start with for them and their
world is different and have any honest
conversation already sets up most people
for success where you don't have to be
disowned by the family
that being said if you're not final 2%
then you have to decide at what point
you're going to live your life instead
of your parents light like if you have
empathy for them and you love to and
understand them you've had the honest
conversation with them and they still
think that you are ridiculous and they
will not support you and if you're gonna
quit your air conditioning repairman job
to be a videographer you are out of the
family that's a pretty extreme like
that's a really really really extreme
case if you're in that final 2% then you
need to decide at what point it's your
life or your parents version of your
life like okay you're you're 90 now you
still listen to your parents or you're
25 or you still listen to your parents
like at what age to say if that's the
result then that's the result that may
mean that the follow my dream I have to
go live with my best friend Danny and
sleep on his couch you don't see me as
underwear every day that's what I'm
gonna live with right so it's not always
great but you have to be able to live
with the consequences that's part of
chasing your dream and that's part of
being an adult
I don't think most people have to go
that way I don't think most people have
to end up on Danny's couch it isn't the
way he's only got one guy great but I
think most people just approach it wrong
so it's not about changing your parents
perspective I know you want their
approval but you don't need it to win
you need your own approval and this will
actually give it to you when you say I'm
doing this for me and I need to know for
me and if I win or if I lose either way
it's great because I bet on myself
against what other people are saying I
think it's one of the hardest things
with family because there's so much love
it's all based out of love all of this
fight and bickering and anger and
resentment really just comes from a
place of trying to love each other and
they're just being a massive
miscommunication around it
now turistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video